mustapha l'air bah oui bonjour vous êtes
pharmacien vous avez 50 3 ans vous êtes
pharmacien à trappes à elancourt aussi
vous êtes président du football club de
trappes vous êtes le président fondateur
de pharma citoyens donc on a beaucoup de
choses à évoquer ensemble
je voudrais qu'on revienne quand même un
petit peu sur votre votre histoire votre
votre passé votre enfance vous êtes né
ou à versailles alors moi je suis né à
versailles dans ce qu'on appelle les
cités de transit c'est à dire qu'à
l'époque c'était le lieu où on pouvait
faire venir un maximum de gens et là je
dis de gens pas forcément d'émigrer mais
c'est énorme et une population très très
mixte mais socialement d'une mêmes
conditions et donc c'était les quartiers
de versailles où il y avait des
bidonvilles d'un côté le quartier de 30
des cités de transit
voilà dans les quartiers donc c'est
versailles mais c'est mal qu'on ne sait
pas c'est pas du château
on a essayé de faire des cabanes au fond
du bois mais la cnpa chat à vos parents
venaient d'algérie
oui et alors donc mon père est arrivé en
48 en france il a travaillé dans l'est
de la france puisqu'il était mineur
mineurs j'entends
deux mines et par l'école et pour le
coup en 48 et dans les années 60 la mer
vient c'est fabien et moi je n'en 61 et
vous allez à l'école vous êtes un mot ni
un des brillants alors très sincèrement
je peux le dire très modestement j'étais
bon élève à l'école et j'étais bonnet
pour une somme pour raisons je crois
c'est que j'étais très curieux parce que
les conditions matérielles je ne
m'explique pas comment j'ai pu faire mes
études les dirigeants étaient nombreux
on était huit dans mes parents six
enfants et on était sur un 48 m² je
crois dans la chambre trois lits
superposés
je ne sais pas où j'ai fait mes études
commente pas facile pour apprendre
jusqu'à 17 ans et après on est passé à
17 ans dans un appartement à lui on
avait une chambre pour deux à las des
années 77 78 noms très sincèrement j'ai
pas souvient l'école l'école donc vous
êtes vous êtes un enfant un élève plutôt
brillant franchement le wpt est le
niveau le permettait pas ce que j'ai eu
toujours le bon niveau j'avais tout de
suite les décorations de l'école de
l'époque les bons points les certificats
les tableaux d'honneur et puis après je
suis allé au lycée jean philippe rallye
c'était bien vu d'être un bon élève il
en fallait un baba parmi les autres des
lèvres je veux dire ma part les
problèmes pour l'épreuve évidemment mais
pour les autres élèves il n'y avait pas
de jets pas ressenti le fait que je sois
premier de la classe est donc rejetée il
en fallait un globalement je me suis
retrouvé premier par défaut pas
forcément en insistant trop lourdement
donc une fille dans fallait un nom qui
m'ont accepté mais
non ce qu'ils étaient il ya vingt ans il
y avait des choses plus difficiles à
vivre dans l'école à l'époque vraiment
l'école de la cité on s'invitait parle
de bulle aujourd'hui mais déjà dans les
années 60 dans le quartier on a là
l'école on sortait de l'école on
rentrait dans le quartier et je me
souviens même plus d'avoir fait mes
devoirs une seule fois d'avoir bref je
vivais on vivait dehors et c'est celle
des murs enfin c'était le même temps
c'est dur c'est ce qu'il ya en même
temps matériellement et matériellement
dur aucun parent aujourd'hui voudraient
vous voudrez voudrait ça pour ses
enfants
une chambre par enfant pouvoir faire ses
études etc
mais j'en ai pas le souvenir j'ai pas
d'autres souvenirs qu une enfance allait
quasiment joyeuse alors ça vous permet
de rentrer après dans un bon lycée dans
le fait d'avoir un état ouais et là
c'est le fait du hasard
je demande à mon grand frère c'est quoi
une une première langue ce qu'on remplit
son dossier soit mais mes parents ne
sachant rien ni lire ni écrire j'ai fait
mes dossiers moi même et il me dit
prends d'anglais c'est facile et c'est
là que j'ai répondu si c'est facile
c'est bon pour tout le monde mais pas
pour moi et j'ai demandé l'allemand un
bon dossier allemand je me retrouve en
une super classe allemand latin grec
on a mal géré conservatoire et là je
sais pas quand ça va moins bien quoi
non pas moi mais tout ce qu'on a avec
moi faisait tous du piano ainsi l'album
dé versailles alors là pour nous
demander tu es au lycée gravité dans
versailles là dedans boss des châteaux
hélas hélas l'accueil il commet un
accueil et l'accueil est fabuleux c'est
une époque où probablement que les
minorités était très très minoritaire
michael sol de la minorisation on a pris
soin de moi même si on a comme il
l'erreur qui n'en est pas une mais celle
de de l'époque de penser que je pourrais
pas faire de longues études
mais le temps où j ai tanaka quand même
avec le temps j étais on s'en est bien
occupée mais en troisième on m'a dit
faut pas non plus exagérer si vous me
trouvez un doigt de la de bach
technology même pas la technique et puis
du coup je vais à marie curie fait un
bac technique et je sort avec un diplôme
de laborantin d'accord et c'est là que
j'arrête mes études et nous allons
rendre mais vous savez quoi après jour
dans la vie active parce que c'est pas
du tout ce que je voulais faire je
rêvais en médecine j'aurai affaire marc
rivet à l'étrave car j'arrivais à des
longues études
un diplôme la peau d'âne et mais encore
une fois nous étions contents a beau les
parents ils étaient ravis déjà avec le
ballet souvient le bac c'était un
événement dans le quartier
on est là dans les années soixante neuf
ans 80 c'était un des jeunes ont salé pu
maintenant et tant mieux mais ça a été
un visage est là et donc vous allez
travailler et puis comment vous un
moment vous dites voilà il faut que
j'envoie de mes études quoi bah tout
simplement parce que on a le sentiment
que on a autre chose à faire à faire que
d'être la porte était votre est
rembourré et donc du coup c'était
l'époque on puisse les années 80 c'est
l'époque des grands frères donc c'est
l'époque également mitterrandienne
l'époque mitterrandienne où on voulait
mettre des gens de la minorité dans la
gestion des minorités mais clark et le
cash devient animateur socioculturel
dans les banlieues d'accord et là je
travaille dans la banlieue de vienne en
mai cité après à chicago à la verrière
et puis ensuite à magny les hameaux donc
je fais quasiment quelques années comme
ça de socio éducatif mais je ne n'arrive
pas à me dire sera facile de continuer
je ne sais pas possible on prend des
gants alors les gars vous avez quel âge
et 25 en 25 ans je suis sorti du système
depuis sept ans et quand vous ne faites
pas de match physique parce qu'un bac
technique c'est très compliqué on dit à
la fac c'est impossible à statistiques
disent des raisons et c'est là que j'ai
cette formule toujours et jusqu'à
maintenant ça me semble poursuit c'est
que ce qu'un être humain peut faire
globalement je peux le faire surtout
s'il s'agit d'offrir des livres et de et
de potasse et il a fallu que vous
repreniez la nationalité française vous
réveillez pas prises pour parfaire le
service militaire
alors ça c'est très particulier
probablement que les gens qui nous
écoutent ne le savent pas remis en 61
jeunes des jeunes est dans un jeu suit
donc ils surveillent départements
français et je n'ai à versailles
je suis donc français sauf que les
accords d'evian prévoyait l'époque
général de gaulle et est tout ce qu ont
signé des accords prévoyaient que tous
ceux qui étaient nés sur le territoire
français avant 1963 premier jour 1963
était automatiquement algérien jeu par
les accords des viandes entre la france
et l'algérie
je suis donc français en 61 je deviens
algériens aux accords d'evian 60 de nos
accords d'evian et la possibilité mais
données de reprendre la cité française
que très tard c'est à dire soit la
majorité soit quand c'est nécessaire et
à l'époque ne s'était même pas dans
l'esprit des uns et des autres que de
vouloir changer de national
personne ne le faisait sauf que ça s'est
imposée à moi sauf que vous êtes
pharmacien et voilà mais en réalité j'ai
pas eu besoin de choisir la cité
française à l'époque parce que avant de
choisir ses française et de prendre
cette option
j'avais eu un décret d'application de
l'état français qui me permettait de
travailler en tant que pharmacien par le
biais d'un décret la g était à des
étrangers d'exercer en france dont j'ai
eu ce décret parce que j'en ai besoin
rapidement c'était donc une erreur de ma
part une omission
en fait j'écris rester français mais je
suis en france donc les premières années
se déroule comme ans pour des années de
pharmaciens à deux pharmaciens là je
suis dans la distribution des
médicaments donc là je rentre dans un
système de logistique et j'ai fait
également un des oss d'oncle en 5e année
je vais à limoges j'emprunte de l'argent
je vais faire un bébé cesse à limoges je
rentre dans la répartition pharmacie djs
de coin stagiaires un des 16 de
logistique en pharmacie maintenant donc
je rends dans la distribution des
médicaments en pharmacie et là je suis
stagiaire est là bien évidemment on veut
pas de moi puis finalement on se dit
tiens il serait probablement intéressant
parce que il ya des minorités à gérer en
ski intelligence cinquantaine avec des
choses
voilà ça permet aussi d'avoir d'en
sortir voilà hélas ce moment là je
deviens responsable d'exploitation sauf
que il ya une agence à villejuif qui va
pas trop bien
hadji c'est une communauté il ya des
communautés de pharmaciens
de diverses horizons on s'y tient
larbaoui da une capacité à passer d'un
milieu un nom de la direction
je deviens le directeur d'une agence de
distribution et deux ans après le
directeur général d'immiscer faire il
sait faire on va l'envoyer en picard ni
sauf que là tout le monde disait juste
pas possible quand ça c'est pas possible
il ya 150 salariés c'est la picardie là
c'est tout le profil
il va y arriver est en fait le casting
n'est pas bon mais j'y suis allé on a
fait un super boulot
oui puisque j'ai pris la première agence
du groupe certains auront à l'époque
et là c'était plus le profil c'était
plus le casting personnel le contenant
mais c'est le contenu et je suis devenu
numéro un du groupe cerp rouen
voilà c'était donc la balle rapide belle
réussite et à quel moment vous dites
mais voilà j'ai envie de m'installer à
mon compte enfants alors en réalité j'ai
besoin de faire beaucoup de choses dans
la répartition je suis passé dans le
groupement de pharmaciens groupe
d'information je suis passé à
l'international de l'international
survenus en france puis après c'est
juste une question de temps alors j'ai
fait l'egypte j'ai été envoyé comme
directeur général pour une structure
égyptienne pour le groupe continental
pharmaceutique du groupe pinault
printemps redoute et là je fais je pars
d'une feuille blanche pour la
structuration d'un répartiteur en egypte
mais j'ai fait également une
joint-venture au maroc 55 ans et avec un
groupe français
pendant 50 57 en belgique une
joint-venture et 5% simplement du
capital en temps normal et puis je
reviens en france et puis chacun chasser
plaisir j'ai 47 ans j'arrive à vouloir
n'y a pas si longtemps mais non mais
c'est le foot
elle a le foot je suis président par le
plus grand des hasards et je dis tiens
et si je faisais quelques mots vous
devenez président défaut de voter mardi
pour pour le base c'est très très très
simple j'ai connu quelqu'un dans ces
banlieues à l'époque et on sert croisé
un jour il était au club de foot il
était trésorier
je peux lui rendre hommage c'était jamal
yalaoui et qui me dit ça va pas très
bien en club de foot on a besoin de
quelqu'un de ton profil pareil le profil
à ceci un service profile quand même
associer le beurre 1
l'associatif mais en même temps manager
en même temps ce truc tu fais ça en même
temps avec un langage en même temps
qu'une opinion loin derrière avec qui on
peut faire confiance m'a probablement
merci patrice et là je dis pourquoi pas
hélas ce qui m'arrive est fabuleux parce
que finalement je parle de la banlieue
des cités et du thym allez on va dire du
de gens que je connaissais bien à
l'époque et je le retrouve alors que
j'ai 47 ans vous aviez parce qu'au
départ vous avez envie de partir peu de
sa démo lieu à la charité partie mais ça
vous êtes dans la vallée de chevreuse
voilà je parcours le monde mes vacances
c'est plutôt voilà j'en suis parti sauf
que j'y reviens tout le temps tout le
temps pour mes pas j'y suis très souvent
ya aussi mais jamais on vous y ramène
aussi coire a d'abord dû parents ils
sont toujours j'adore y aller et puis en
même temps je voulais dit a lancé une
partie de mon enfance qui échappe au
regretté
oui bah ouais et dont l enfant très
modeste je pourrais vous parler pendant
des heures sur la modestie et la
personne n'avait pas géré par les ports
dans le désert parce que mais
globalement malheureusement l'émission
aurait été remis et donc c'était modeste
mais chaleureux
en l'occurrence surtout avec des parents
que comme j'ai d'ailleurs super mais je
ferai donc peut-être une parenthèse dans
cette histoire c'est que je me considère
comme le produit de ce que mes parents
ont fait ça c'est pour ça que j'étais
tout le temps je suis issu de la
start-up nabawi les start-ups et
toujours bill gates toujours les gens
n'ont rien dit ariane lareau
on va certainement parce que l'on pose
on va se retrouver une autre fois bio
parlera peut-être un peu plus de deux
filles de traves de fermat doute rien de
votre vie aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup aux salaires bas oui
merci